what you're looking at is a 30 foot
18,000 pound chunk of consumer
confidence
people generally don't buy recreational
vehicles unless they're feeling pretty
good about the economy and right now
sales of these things are moving fast
now the companies benefiting our major
businesses like tor industries Winnebago
and Fleetwood enterprises which was kind
enough to drop off this beast in midtown
Manhattan this week for us to give it a
test drive oh hey hey all right Kevin
Sam in the market sell me this thing
what's the cool what are the coolest
features well one of the things that's
unique about this vehicle it's this
retractable wall it comes down and
that's a third bed right you got a
flat-screen TV you've got of course a
full kitchen an oven cooktop stove
refrigerator with freezer
and a microwave the bed slides out so
you're gonna have an extra walking space
in there and then over here this room
slides out as well us drivers are
expected to buy about 44,000 of these
this year that's 14% more than they did
in 2013 say I just bought this thing
what do I need to know take your turns
wider and watch your mirrors what kind
of mileage you get on this thing 10 to
12 miles per gallon a pretty good
mileage for a house all right first turn
we got a crossing guard
you got some pedestrians take or wide
bonus points for taking out the BMW yeah
and this came straight out of Indiana
that's right 83% of RVs in North America
are made in India all right 20 miles an
hour
look out try not to hit this bunch of
cones our destination
so great doesn't hit anything and right
next to the curve look at that
almost